die neurochirurgie aber natürlich viele
patienten bei denen ist auch zu ende
geht es heißt wie eine schwere blutung
haushalts durch irgendeinen ganz
bösartigen weit fortgeschrittenen tumor
fans junge patienten mit kleinen kindern
das gibt mir noch sehr viel mehr
angekündigt über den leitenden notarzt
und verkehrs unfall involviert ist eine
motor mit zwei kleinen kindern
routiniert sind wir immer aber bei dem
kind natürlich immer etwas angespannter
als normal mal auf den rücken gucken
es ist so dass
das organ ist auf dem weg hierher
[Musik]
eigentlich ein gutes ordern aldi blut
gaswerte war nicht optimal das sind
komplexe abläufe aber wir haben ein sehr
gut trainiertes team ja das hat sich
über die jahre auch positiv entwickelt
das ist vielmehr das ist ein neues leben
ich würde gerne die welt retten habe ich
kannst dich deswegen habe ich kleine
angebracht
jahresverlauf
wenn du ihn einlädt dann das problem mit
mir ich werde mich daran haben
[Musik]
ich kann auch gerne den polizeiruf
meldet nicht aufhören
eine nadel
[Musik]
achtung
wenn man zum beispiel auch in
reanimation situationen steht wo man
ganz genau weiss man macht gerade alles
tut alles man hat alle medizinischen
möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft aber es geht
nicht weiter haben dann fühlt man sich
hilflos dann ist es einfach so da kommt
man nicht mehr weiter
[Musik]
ich denke wir hier auch das ist
irgendwie ungeordnete aktivität das ist
auch
ich war richtig
eine gewisse distanz hat man auf jeden
fall aber man freut sich immer wenn man
einen baby- oder ein kleines lebewesen
die atemhilfe und ist da noch dran das
heißt das war ein bisschen sauerstoff im
grunde in die lunge gepustet will
wirklich
nur ganz kleine frühgeborene auf die
welt kommen dann ist doch schon eine
angespannte situation
und das glaube ich für viele eltern
schwierig sich dann darauf einzustellen
und mit dieser neuen realität dann klar
zu kommen sie waren ein sehr netter
patient ich gebe sie ungern her aber
irgendwann muss es ja passiert alles
gute
akut menschen helfen zu können menschen
denen es schlecht geht zu einer besseren
situation verhelfen das finde ich das
privileg dass nicht jeder job mit sich
bringt und das haben wir in unserem job
[Musik]